[Applause]
well it has been quite a year for our
first guest his latest album tickets to
my downfall debuted at number one
on the billboard 200. that's right
andy just won an american music awards
for favorite rock artists
he is someone that we all just love so
much oh and he's a budding nail
entrepreneur and artist as well
please welcome someone i've been so
excited to meet and talk to it's machine
gun kelly
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm so excited so
your new nail collection
undone lacquer yeah this is the one i'm
thinking i like by the way what are you
wearing because this looks so
interesting is that this that's this i
was i was bored this is also this was in
the dark my like my my bedroom's very
dark there's not lights in there so it's
like it's kind of like i was just like
waving it around and this is what we
turned out with so i don't look at mine
but i love this one i love all of them
by the way i'll take different colors
too
i'm so i'm also
i'm like having a really weird day so i
just want you to i don't want to
come off like i'm cold or i'm like shy
i'm just
i'm a little insular and i'm just having
an odd day
you're in a really safe space
um the other day i walked in here and i
started crying um at the beginning of
the intro we started hearing a pandemic
and everybody was terrified and i think
this show this space was born in a time
where we get to keep it very real and be
honest
maybe you can feel that in the room and
feel safe
i think i'm
new to being vulnerable outside of songs
so it's like like i see a lot of
pictures of me
and there's like smiles on them and i'm
always like it's just weird though
because i didn't feel good at all that
day and i
i kind of
am sick of smiling on days when i don't
feel like smiling and i feel like this
odd pressure because i don't want
um like my fans to
think that i'm taking something for
granted so if like i accept an award and
i'm like super smiley but behind the
scenes i was really
there was like stuff going on or i
didn't feel i don't know i like a lot of
what i do is for other people and i
haven't given myself the
the time to just
accept that it's okay to not be okay so
i i didn't just my whole point is i just
didn't want to bring that into the show
i'd love to talk about funny stuff and
anything that you have for me i would
love to just like i would love to just
get out of what um what i'm doing and
like
i don't mean to sound creepy but i like
you so much more
i really do in fact we were just talking
about where different people were from
and someone was like
why do you know utah and i was like i
went there to go change my life and
i just you know i went through a really
painful divorce and i wasn't doing very
well and i just wanted to go talk to
some people and how to
pull myself out of a hole and i had
these two kids that i had to fight for
and
i needed help so i started reaching out
to different people and eventually i
really made some big sweeping changes in
my life
and i got i got on a whole new track not
back on track but a brand new one that i
helped build
with other people asking for support and
like i i'm all over the place too you
really are in the right space
who do you like go to for support when
you're feeling like this
well my girl is really centered and kind
of was like the one who encouraged me to
face my past and stuff and and
pick out
what it is that that i'm running from
and why i like put on those smiles that
i don't want to wear and stuff like that
and so that that was
big for me and i think also i was
like i was just walking behind my
daughter in the airport the other day
and like she just has this walk it's
this pure like bounce
she's so
excited for life like she's so young in
her life and i've experienced so much in
my life i just pray to
every god that exists that like she
keeps that bounce forever and doesn't
like no one interferes with that and
that she like that i always get to stand
back and watch her have that bounce like
i will take any amount of torture that
it
that would come her way if it can just
be on me so that she can keep that
forever because that's something that
it's like it's worth living for to see
that you know she's so
like
her voice is so sweet and it's not
tainted with like
what the world has to
offer and
anyway remember when you were in 50
first dates
so
in love with my children
i never knew what life or love was until
i was born the day they were
they changed everything for me
and whatever experiences i had or went
through they just made me think
i have to figure this out and
and and become a strong wise person for
them and now my daughter
the other day i got lost driving and i
was just flipping out behind the wheel
and my daughter was like mom
you need to take a deep breath
and calm down yeah and i was like yeah
and i was like i just was so grateful to
her for being like now the roles are
reversed yeah no that's a she's she's
like my mom what was the last thing your
daughter told you
that like
was smarter than what you would have
said or done the other day i had to
witness myself being a rule follower for
the first time in her breaking rule for
the first time i was like
oh god what's happening i was at the uh
we i took her to greece
and uh her megan and i went to the
parthenon
and uh we went to acropolis and we got
up there and i made the stupid mistake
of like looking at the section that's
like restricted and
when i was like i bet all the cool
stuff's in there and
megan was like
well shouldn't we go and i was like nah
probably not i watched the mummy and
national treasure and all the people
that touch things that aren't supposed
to be touched and watched it go really
bad and uh
she was like well casey do you want to
go and i was like
in case she was like yeah and i was like
oh god i'm just gonna stay here
and they
went across the ropes and then like the
door burst open they were like what are
you doing and i was like and they
screamed and like ran away and we got
kicked out the parking lot but it was uh
yes
but uh
it's a proud moment there was also like
a proud mom was like this isn't a proud
mama but there was a i got a call one
time or school was like hey so you know
your daughter got into
a thing with this boy and i was like
what happened they were like the boy was
talking bad about you
and i was like
[Music]
good job don't ever do that again but i
love you so much
i know i'm such a like a rebel and i'm
trying to get it so right with these
girls yeah me too but like i grew up you
know
like a ruffian and i sometimes i'm like
oh you just
want to get it so right
this time but like you know leopards
don't totally change their spots
um
so it's always like striking that
interesting balance
um i'm really humorous with them i
definitely swear in front of them
accidentally oh my god i love when
people come and they like say the word
damn or something they're like oh i'm
sorry and i'm like sorry do you know
what i just said like
yes exactly i also um pull the car over
and like pee in the bushes all the time
cool
and because i don't want to bother going
into a gas station
nothing's better than an outside pee we
call it sneaky pee
and so i'll literally left with a car
and the kids are like sneaky pee again
don't you love when it's cold outside
and you're like oh dude like like like
it's like
like in a place like this yeah like that
does that yeah here's the question that
okay goes back to your other thing like
when you are smiling but you don't feel
like it
how have you accepted that about
yourself i can't convince myself like i
yeah i'll walk back
from this interview this is this is how
it'll go i'll walk upstairs after this
is done and i'll go
i sucked didn't i suck it was just like
and then
like uh
yeah it's just
is this what like mori was like because
i feel like
i've this is the first audience i've
ever witnessed that's done anything
besides like like this is the first one
this is the first audience i've ever
seen someone go no
i'm telling you we literally encourage
them like if you want to hiss yeah
like we we keep it real here i'm
incapable that's why i kind of asked you
about the advice about the smile because
i am incapable
of
not
being myself
and that's a lot of different things but
it's very real and very honest i like
the truth of people
i like the colors and the light and the
dark and the in between the churroscuro
if you will
i like i like to keep it real
but i don't know who i am
i don't i don't know i don't i don't
know what exists outside of the the
paper and pen and the recordings that i
make like that was that's who i
have been comfortable with the whole
time right so i think that that is the
real you in those writings and with that
pen and with the guitar is that a part
of you
for sure those are my stories like
that's that is me
but i can
i can't exist my entire life as a song
right like the song's over after three
minutes and 15 seconds so i have to
what do i do with the rest of the 24
hours that i have to exist i was born
with the umbilical cord around my neck
you were so even from the beginning like
my life hasn't made sense because it was
already
you know trying to be taken away from me
from the second i came out and then
you proceed and then you're in fifth
grade or you're in whatever it is and
you know i had leg hair before everybody
else and everyone was like that's weird
ew and i was like skinny and taller than
everybody else and i like had to figure
things out by myself and i figured them
out not from encouragement but rather
being
made fun of or being attacked and then
i ran away to my headphones and then
you know when
tupac becomes who your
like advice is coming from and stuff
like that you
you know who or whoever is in your
headphones like and in movies and stuff
like that those are
they almost seem like it you you engulf
yourself in a fantasy world and so that
means that you don't accept who you are
in real life because you just want to be
with these what
is
in fantasy i too was like left out on my
own and i made a lot of mistakes in my
own parenting
um ones that i still have like triggers
to this day of like doing to my own kids
which i fight really hard not to ever do
um
and i think when you grow up with like
dysfunctional parents you're like oh god
i don't want to grow up to be that
dysfunctional parent and i will do
anything i can to like fight against
that
repeating of history
um
but
i'm so glad because it's the only life i
know
and whatever it is that has happened to
you in your life i think you have also
turned it into
incredible art
um you have found a channel
i don't know if things were meant to
happen the way they were meant to happen
but i see that you've done so much with
it and made such a life for yourself and
something that you don't even just keep
to yourself but you share with other
people
i i think you've done a really good job
at
figuring out
how to take care of yourself and putting
beautiful things out into the world it's
interesting to know that's your
perspective
because um i like you i like you so much
and
if there's any consolation like i had to
eat a bowl of macaroni and cheese
because i had a hard day at work because
you know i i'm still learning on this
job and i i just eviscerate myself all
the time
so i understand yeah but don't
don't let yourself like get in the way
of the things that people love about you
which is like
you know we're we're scared to have a
learning
[Music]
curve in our life because we're
comments make us feel like we're
supposed to have it right at that very
moment and
what they don't realize is that
life is growth like if someone has a
desire to grow and they they show it and
we should encourage it it's odd that i
don't know sometimes the world
disappoints me i i don't i don't mean to
bring that into this i know my publicist
is back they're just like what are you
doing you're supposed to talk about
nationals
your publicist is probably like
okay
i just my aesthetic eye is killing me i
gotta redo this hand okay please um
by the way
okay so if you can see those things that
me and your daughter are you gonna be
able to see that in yourself because
everything you just said about all of us
i see in you
excuse me hold on
i'm sorry sorry i'm so sorry
but i had to do that
i um
i really hope so you know i wanna i
wanna stick around and see how the story
ends so
i think you're holding the pen
i think you are the writer
yeah speaking of writing
how do you like that for a segway
dovetail maybe i don't suck at this job
so badly
will you tell me about this book hotel
diablo yeah i am a huge lover of graphic
novels i think it's an escape into a
fantasy world
not just
leaving it up to your mind for those who
can't read words and put visuals to them
but it kind of does does both
there's no superheroes and capes in this
comic there's no
i mean i think it's almost just like a
reflection of what we've been talking
about when you get like
dark and deep does megan go like oh
honey or she like lighten up
oh no
she's the most compassionate person ever
but i think like my dark is just so dark
she's like oh god
like she but no she's she's
super compassionate she's the nicest
person i've ever met and like she
she loves me for me and all my crazy so
i
what tactic does she use
to sort of
open one up that we could all benefit
from because we're all trying to do that
for each other exorcism
[Music]
some real demons in there that we gotta
get out
i have literally reagan upstairs like
can someone bring her down so i can
show and prove can i ask how you guys
met
did you get set up on a date
we were filming a movie and
uh which i which ironically i took
because
the only the only reason i took the
movie was because they were like your
scenes with megan fox and i was like
i'll take the movie and um
but i
stayed outside the trailer and my gut is
always right and i'm grateful for it
because for some reason i knew she would
invite me to lunch and then all of a
sudden someone came over and they were
like megan wants to know if you want to
have lunch in a trailer
and i was like
oh my god i'm so surprised yeah
absolutely had like a whole bag packed
like
like and uh i went in there
and uh
she said
how do you feel and i said i'm lost and
she said let's find you and i was like
it killed me i was like she i mean she
she was cupid and i was i was
you got hit by her arrow
right in the
um by the way i have someone here who
wants to visit oh
thank you you mentioned exorcist
thank you daniel
oh my god hi
should we do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i i relate
i feel you so every morning um reagan
greets us in the uh writer's room
because this was what my daughter wanted
for halloween
and then i bought it and i brought it
and then she was like okay i changed my
mind it's too scary
so now she's been living in our office
well since you're here
[Applause]
keep being that keep breaking down those
walls
keep making your music keep feeling your
feelings smile when you want to don't
when you don't want to
make that be
okay for other people maybe your
discomfort will be
a gateway and an open door and a bridge
for someone else
who might feel that feeling but doesn't
know what to do with it that's that's
why i named it undone because i was like
you're not you shouldn't be done like
changing you shouldn't be done evolving
and it's like as simple as
nail polish can seem it's still like
action of meditating or breathing is
also simple it's like all i have to do
is breathe but it is wild like to see
what breathing like deep breaths so like
those things
yeah yeah it's
absolutely blew my mind what that
one word has done
you shouldn't you shouldn't be done i i
i watched my father change like right
before he passed because he wasn't done
and like he wasn't
scared to like make a step even in the
age that he was and in the state that he
was and like the coolest thing my dad
did i remember like
for so many years i hid my tattoos from
him i had been tattooed since i was 14
years old but
uh and i revealed them when i was 18 or
19 something like that like
i mean he got a plateful i was like i
have a baby on the way and also
[Laughter]
he was like
oh my god it was happening
and uh but he was on the hospital bed
and like
he like
lifted up
the gown
and he had a tattoo on his hand
and i was like it was a jesus tattoo of
course but uh
i i thought it was so rad he wasn't
done becoming the person that he wanted
to be until
it was his time and that's maybe why his
time came because like he finally he
there was one last step he had to take
and he took it and
that was fire i think we have a lot to
talk about like with our dads by the way
i just can't stress to about what my
publicist is back there thinking i can't
pass out
she's gonna be like i don't know if you
know this about me
but um i was actually gonna be a
director and then i had directed a movie
and it was called whip it about roller
derby because i just thank you i love um
the world of roller derby it's such a
perfect metaphor for life like we create
these little names and we pretend to be
these little alter-ego superheroes and
we want to do something badass but we
want family and camaraderie and
showmanship and to break out of our
shells
and um i just thought that's where my
life was going and then i had two kids
and i kind of wanted to stop acting and
change my life so that i could be
a parent for them and be present and
then i didn't know where my life was
taking me it got divorced and finally
found myself here in this beautiful
space
that is the happiest i've been
in so many years of my life
but i am a filmmaker and editing is one
of my uh strong suits
and if you don't mind i would love to
take this time we spent together and
craft something really beautiful
and very tailored and thoughtful about
who you are
and
true to this time
my goal is to surprise you
with
i i want to make you happy with it and
and i think i really know how to do that
okay and you we have to trust you
beautiful clay
and i'm gonna make this sculpture out of
it and i'm really really excited because
i think i know how to make something
very true to you
actually hit the things we're supposed
to talk about but find our way through
this dynamic cool approach that you took
and i can't wait to show you what i make
should we take the cameras backstage
when i walk in and my publicist is like
[Applause]
i just it's like because the funniest
part this is this is also funny i go
she looked at me before i walked out
here she was like
all right based off of the last 15
minutes from being around you
do you really want to go out there and i
was like dude i'm not going to bring any
of this out there
anyway what would your roller derby name
in real life yeah because i was smashley
simpson oh that's hollywood in the movie
we had babe ruthless and rosa sparks
what would yours be
uh
oh brad hit
brad hit yes that's a derby name yeah
i'm brad hit your brad hitt and i am
lucille brawl
that's hard
that's hard
yeah
and lucille brawl
[Applause]
that's hard
sorry to leave you out i'll do respect i
never want to see you again ever in my
life
she just wants to be loved too please
stand up with me yeah of course i have
to tell you
i was excited to meet you and i thought
that i really
liked you
she's like and now yeah
i never want to see you and now
i have to tell you i
love you
we'll be right back thank you very much
[Music]
you